Today-- guys,
this is gonna upset you--
today is Harry Potter's
37th birthday.
-(groans) I know.
-Whoa!
So-so, break... 'Cause it
just makes everyone feel old.
But, hey, go ahead
and break out the Butterbeer
or, if you're
a designated driver
or a teetotaler, like me,
then break out the I Can't
Believe It's Not Butterbeer!
And because the end
of The Deathly Hallows
is set in September 2017,
this is how Harry
actually looks right now.
This is how they look.
It's sort of like that sad,
late-30s guy you see
wandering the frozen food
section at Trader Joe's.
That's what he looks like.
Just think about what his life
is like right now.
He's a 37-year-old dropout
who peaked in high school,
married his childhood sweetheart
and is trying to raise a family
on the combined pay
of a government employee
and a newspaper reporter.
Voldemort couldn't kick his ass,
but time definitely did.
He's just trying
to relive his...
Yeah.
So, with Harry Potter
pushing middle age,
what is a spell
a 37-year-old wizard would use?
-Yassir.
-An invisibility cloak
to help him avoid
paying child support.
-All right, points.
-What's up? Where we at?
(laughter)
Chris D'Elia.
Viagracadabra.
Yes, points. Very nice.
Yeah.
(cheering and applause)
I mean... that's kind of cute.
The spell he would probably use
is Petrificus Totalus,
but that's fine.
Brian Posehn.
Hold my wand.
I had too much Patronus.